المترجم: Nour Shaaban
المدقّق: Riyad Almubarak
(تصفيق)
مرحباً
جميعنا في أيّام العيد نتجمع،
الأولاد والأحفاد،
ويصبح كلٌ منا يعّد مجموع عيديته،
والشاطر فيهم الذي يجمع أكبر عدد من النقود.
في يوم من أيّام العيد، أتت إليّ أختي
الصغيرة وسألتني،
أختي الصغيرة اسمها ميس، قامت ميس
بسؤالي: "أسماء، كم لديك من النقود؟"
قمت بإخبارها أنه لديّ نقداً نقود أكثر
مما لديها.
ميس كان شعورها في هذه اللحظة كهذا.
( مثل الصورة)
ولكن في الواقع كانت كالصورة الثانية.
(جيف بيزوز) مؤسس موقع أمازون،
أشهر موقع تجاري إلكتروني على الانترنت.
تم تصنيفه كأغنى رجل بالعالم لعام 2018
تقدّر ثروته بأكثر من 130 مليار دولار.
(جبف) بدأ موقعه كمكتبة إلكترونية بسيطة
من غرفة النوم.
لربما جميعنا حلمنا أن نكون أغنياء
في يوم من الأيام لكن لم نعرف كيف.
في الكتاب الشهير (الأب الغني والأب الفقير)
يتكلم فيه المؤلف (روبرت كايوساكي)
عن أهمّ وأشهر مبادىء عالم الثراء.
سوف أقوم مشاركتكم بأهم ثلاثة مبادىء
ذكرها من وجهة نظري.
المبدأ الأول:
"يعمل الأغنياء كي يتعلموا".
بعكس الباقين
الذين يعملون من أجل النقود.
المبدىء الثاني: يستطيع الأغنياء التمييز
بين الأصول وبين الخصوم.
الAssets=الأصول
ما معنى الأصول والخصوم؟
assets والliabilities
الأصول هي الأشياء والموارد
التي تدخل إلى جيبك النقود،
مثل السندات، الأسهم، العقارات،
بعكس الخصوم التي هي الأشياء
والموارد التي تأخذ من جيبك النقود،
مثل القروض، الرهن، بطاقات الائتمان.
بهذه المعادلة، الغني هو الشخص الذي
لديه قيمة الأصول أعلى من قيمة الخصوم.
دعوني أعطيكم مثال،
جميعنا، حين يصبح معنا نقوداً،
نفكّر أن نشتري بيت،
البيت ممكن يكون أصل وممكن
أن يكون خصم في نفس الوقت.
إذا قمت بشراء بيت وقمت بوضعه
للإيجار، وأصبح يأتيك منه دخل
شهري أو سنويّ، ففي هذه الحالة
البيت يعتبر أصل.
أما إن قمت بشراء البيت وأصبحت
تدفع من أجله تصليحات، دهان، أثاث
فالبيت بهذه الحالة يعتبر خصم،
فالأغنياء يشترون أصول لا خصوم.
المبدىء الثالث: يستثمر الأغنياء بمدخراتهم.
ربما نستطيع جميعاً معرفة الحصول
على المال، من خلال العمل
في وظيفة معيّنة، أو من خلال بيع شيء
ولكن لا نعلم كيفية إدارة النقود بطريقة
تمكنها من زيادة قيمتها.
النقود من غير إدارة، تطير مع الريح.
ماذا يفعل الأغنياء؟
يقومون بتحديد حساب توفيري
خاص بهم، يقومون بتحديد بما نسبته
من 3% إلى 10 % من قيمة دخلهم السنوي،
ويقومون بوضعه في هذه الحساب،
فأنت مثلاً لو دخلك الشهريّ 100 دينار،
قم بوضع 3 دنانير في هذا الحساب كل شهر،
وقم بصرف ال97 دينار الباقية،
3+3+3 في النهاية سيصبح لديك مبلغ جيد.
الآن تعلمنا ما معنى الغنيّ، وتعلمنا
كيف نصبح أغنياء،
وهذا يعني أننا يجب أن نبدأ بأول طريقة،
وهي الحصول على المال.
صراحةً برأي بما أن الأهل موجودين
أسأل الله أن يحفظهم،
وهم البنك الوحيد الذي يمكن
الأخذ منه بدون قروض، ضمانات وكمبيالات.
عندما نتخرج، أوّل ما نفكر به
هو القيام بشيء ألا وهو الوظيفة،
الشيء الجميل في الوظيفة هو أنه
مهما عملت خلال الشهر،
فأنت تعلم أن هناك راتب ثابت
سيدخل جيبك في نهاية الشهر.
رويداً رويداً، تبدأ بالتطوير من مواهبك
ومهاراتك،
وتبدأ بالإعلان عن خدماتك والعمل
بشكل مستقل (freelancer)،
ورويداً رويداً، يبدأ العملاء بالدفع
لك مقابل هذه الخدمة،
مشكلة هاتين الطريقتين
أن الوقت يساوي النقود،
بمعنى أنه طالما أن تعمل فهناك
نقود تدخل جيبك،
ولكن في اليوم الذي تقرر فيه
عدم رغبتك بالعمل، أو تشعر بالملل،
أو مريض، في هذا اليوم لن يدخل
جيبك قرش.
لهذا السبب يفكر الأغنياء بطريقة أخرى.
يقوم الأغنياء
بتأسيس مشروعهم الخاص،
يستقدمون موظفين إليهم،
يعرضون خدمات أكثر
ويحصلون على المزيد من النقود،
ويقومون بتأسيس نظام عمل خاص بهم.
ورويداً رويداً، ومن خلال الأسرار
التي قمنا بإخباركم إياها،
يبدأون بالحصول على نقود أكثر،
بعد ذلك، يقومون باستثمار نقودهم
بأفكار ومشاريع الآخرين
ويصبح اسمهم (مستثمر).
بعد ذلك، يأتي موظف الضرائب،
ويقوم بكل سهولة بأخذ نصف النقود
التي قام النصف منا بجمعها،
فكّر معي، لو أنت مستثمر،
ما هو أكبر مبلغ ممكن أن تستثمر فيه
في حياتك؟
1000؟ مليون؟ إن شاء الله
جوابي إليكم هو، infinity=لا نهائي
لأن الاستثمار الحقيقي هو استثمارك في نفسك،
وأنت ستتمكن لاحقاً من الحصول
على كل شيء تحلم به في حياتك.
من أشهر المستثمرين الحاليين (وارين بافت)
تقدر ثروته بأكثر من 86 مليار دولار.
قام بالاستثمار بالعديد من الشركات،
متل Apple ،IPM، وغيرها.
يقول (بافيت) بإحدى المقابلات:
"استثمارك في نفسك هو أفضل شيء
يمكن أن تفعله في حياتك".
إذا قمت بالاستثمار في موهبتك،
لن يستطيع أحد أخذ هذا الشيء منك لاحقاً،
في عالم المال والأعمال أي شيء ممكن
أن يحصل.
من الممكن أن تنزل قيمة العملة،
من الممكن أن يحدث تضخم مالي،
ولكن إن قمت بتمييز نفسك
وقمت بتطوير موهبتك،
فأنت عندها تكون قد ملكت أفضل مورد بالحياة.
أشهر الشركات العالمية تعلمت
وفهمت هذا المبدأ،
وعلمت أن المورد البشري ألا وهو الموظفين،
أهم مورد بالنسبة إليهم،
ودائماً يقومون بالإعلان عنه
أن الموظفين أولاً والعملاء ثانياً،
لأن الموظفين هم الذين يقومون بالتعامل
المباشر مع عملائهم
وبالتالي بالمحافظة عليهم وبالرفع
من كفاءتهم،
هذا الشيء يزيد من إنتاجيتهم
ويحفّز من إبداعهم
أكثر من 12 مرة بناءً على الإحصائيات.
وعندما نقول موظفين وإنتاجية
يعني نقود أكثر.
شركة (Zappos) العالمية، أشهر موقع
إلكتروني يبيع الأحذية عبر الانترنت،
تم استحواذه من شركة (Amazon) مؤخراً،
تعلن شركة (zappos) عن أنفسهم
باسم (عائلة Zappos).
اعتمدوا مبدأ التواصل المفتوح
ما بين الموظفين والإدارة،
يقومون بالتفاعل ومحاولة إنشاء
بيئة تفاعلية بين الموظفين،
وأن كل موظف له رأي بهذه الشركة
بغضّ النظر عن طبيعة عمله،
والتحدي الذي يواجهونه الآن
هو أن يقوموا بإيجاد موظف
قادر على التأقلم مع الحياة
التي أوجدوها لأنفسهم.
ربما ستقولون لي أن هذه الشركات كبيرة،
ولديها الكثير من النقود وتستطيع الدفع،
في عالم وادي السيليكون، ربما أشهر مصطلح
نسمعه بعالم الشركات الناشئة،
وهو موقع جغرافيّ موجود في سان فرانسيسكو
فيه أشهر تجمّع
للشركات العالمية الإلكترونية
في وادي السيليكون،
يسألون المستثمرين،
"عندما تريدون الدفع للشركات، على ماذا
تبحثون؟ بمن تريدون الاستثمار؟
على الأرباح التي تتوقعوها من المشروع؟
أو على الفكرة الخرافية التي لا مثيل لها؟"
الجواب الصادم كان أن المستثمرين
يبحثون عن شغف صاحب المشروع
الذي يمكنه من تحقيق فكرته
مهما كانت التحديات،
وعلى العلاقة التي تربطه
بينه وبين أعضاء الفريق المتكامل،
الذي كل واحد فيهم يعرف
المهارة التي لديه والتي تكمل الفريق.
كيف تستثمر بنفسك؟
ما الذي يمكنك القيام به
بعد سماعك عن النقود والأغنياء؟
كيف تبدأ؟ وما هي أول
نقطة تستطيع البدأ فيها؟
الخطوة الأولى: حدد دائرة كفاءتك الشخصية.
ما هو الشيء، أو الخدمة، أو القيمة المميّزة
التي تستطيع القيام بها وتقدّمها بشكل متقن
كل مرّة بنفس المستوى،
خذ ورقة وقم بكتابة أهم نقاط القوة
والميّزات التي لديك،
وحاول صنع تقاطعات بين دائرة
اهتماماتك، مهاراتك وشخصيتك،
وممكن أن تكون هذه نقطة لانطلاقتك.
من بداية عملي من عمر ال21 سنة إلى الآن
27 سنة، تنقلت ما بين معلّمة،
كنت أصغر معلّمة في المدرسة، أدرّس
نظام الIG للصف الرابع والخامس،
محاضرة بالجامعة، وكنت أقوم بتدريس
طلّاب أكبر مني أحياناً،
ومديرة مشروع بأكبر
منظمة غير حكومية بالمملكة،
وحالياً، مؤسسة لمشروعي الخاص
بمجال التدريب والاستشارات.
(تصفيق)
(شكراً)
في كل جانب وبكل دور بهذه الحياة
وجدت واكتشفت في نفسي شيء
لم أكن أعرفه عن نفسي من قبل.
وقام بالتأثير بشكل مباشر على شخصيتي.
الخطوة الثانية هي أن تتعلّموا.
أنا لا أتكلم هنا عن التعلم الأكاديمي
والممنهج الذي نتلقّاه في المدارس والجامعات
والذي هو فقط نقل للمعرفة.
إنما أتكلم عن التعلم الذاتي،
الذي تقوم أنت فيه بالبحث عن المعلومة،
الذي تقوم أنت فيه بمعرفة
ما هي الخبرة
أو المهارة التي تبحث عنها.
في أستراليا في إحدى الإحصائيات
قاموا بسؤال مدراء قسم الموارد البشرية
بما هي الصفة أو المهارة التي يقومون
بالبحث عنها في الموظفين عند تعيينهم،
80 بالمئة من الإجابات الأولى كانت:
"قدرة الموظف على التعلم الذاتي".
لأن هذا الشيء يحفزهم،
يزيد من إنتاجيتهم،
ويجعلهم يتطورون بمهنتهم أكثر.
النقطة الثالثة: عزّز من مهارات التواصل.
كيف تتوقف؟ كيف تعرّف عن نفسك؟
كيف تتكلم عن مهنتك والخدمات التي تقدمها؟
من خلال عملي مع طلاب المشاريع
وأصحاب المشاريع والجامعات،
لأساعدهم وأرشدهم بتأسيس
مشروعهم على أرض الواقع،
الذي وجدته هو أن الرياديّ
الذي لديه علاقات هو الشخص
الذي ينهي أموره بشكل أسرع.
أنا لا أتكلم عن فيتامين واو (الواسطة)،
لا، أنا أتكلم عن دائرة معارفك الشخصية،
من هم الأشخاص المتخصصين، الموجهين
والمرشدين بالنسبة لك؟
وممكن أن يكونوا بنفس الوقت الأهل
والأصدقاء الذين يقومون بدعمك عند الحاجة.
لو أعطيت كلٌ منكم حبة مارشميلو،
كم شخص منكم سيأكلها؟
يا للعجب!
ولكن إن قلت لكم أن تنتظروا
لمدة ساعة وسأقوم بإعطائكم حبتين
بدلاً من حبة، من سيقوم بالانتظار؟
هذا الاختبار اسمه اختبار المارشميلو،
أوجدته جامعة ستانفورد بالستينيات تقريباََ،
يعتبر من أشهر الاختبارات النفسية
التي ممكن أن تتنبأ بالناجحين في المستقبل.
وجدوا، قاموا بدراسة الأولاد،
وقاموا بمتابعتهم على مر السنوات،
وجدوا أن الأولاد الذين قاموا بأكل حبة
المارشميلو فوراً
هم الأشخاص الذين هم الآن حالياً
يحبّون الاختصارات بحياتهم،
الذين لايحبون أن يتعبوا، لا يحبون
أن يعملوا، يريدون المتعة الفورية.
ولكن بعكس الأولاد الذين انتظروا
وقاموا بأكل حبتين بدلاً من حبة،
معظم هؤلاء الأشخاص حالياً،
أنجح، رواتبهم أعلى، لهم تأثير واسم
قويّ في المجتمع، وحتى حياتهم
الزوجية أفضل بكثير.
وهذا هو سرّ النجاح بالحياة...
الصبر، المثابرة، وأنا أحب أن أسمّيه
العناد الإيجابي،
أن تضع هدفك في عقلك وأن تعرف
حقاً أن تحققه عندما تريد،
وهذا الذي يجعل العدّاء يركض
لآخر جزء من الثانية،
لأنه يعلم أن آخر جزء ممكن أن
يأثر على النتيجة.
ذاتك هي أفضل مشروع ممكن
أنت أن تستثمره في حياتك،
لأن إذا أنت لم تضع حدود لنفسك
فالمكسب بالتأكيد سيكون لا نهائي.
وهكذا في المرة القادمة، عندما تجلس
مع أخيك أو أختك الصغيرة،
لا تقوم بالضحك عليها
وإخبارها بأنها هي أغنى منك،
أخبرها كيف تصبح مستثمرة مثلك
عندما تكبر وشكراً.
(تصفيق)